the coordinates of a and B are as
follows we have been asked to find the
midpoint of a B give it a try
the most obvious way would be to plot
these two points form the segment find
its length using the Pythagoras theorem
mark the midpoint and then find its
coordinates unfortunately you won't have
so much time in your competitive exams
finding the midpoint should take you a
maximum of five seconds the x coordinate
of the midpoint is the average of the
x-coordinates of the end points the
x-coordinates of a and b are 3 and 1 the
average will be 3 plus 1 over 2 this is
the x coordinate of the midpoint and the
y coordinate as you would have guessed
will be the average of the Y coordinates
of the endpoints it will be minus 1 plus
3 over 2 the coordinates of the
midpoints are 2 comma 1
remember average of the x-coordinates
and average of the y-coordinates but
midpoint problems are not always this
easy in the next problem we are given
that p is the midpoint of the part of
the line between the axes we are given
the midpoint this time and we are asked
for the slope of that line let me be
honest this is not very straight forward
but try finding the slope
let's try understanding this with the
help of a coordinate plane the only
thing we are given is that 2 comma minus
3 is the midpoint of some line segment
this is tricky read the question
carefully it is the midpoint of the part
of the line between the X and the y-axis
now try drawing different lines passing
through P one line we can draw is like
this
it passes through the first third and
the fourth quadrant so maybe the
question is talking about P being the
midpoint of this segment it is formed
between the X and the y axis is there
any other way in which a line can be
drawn through P can we have a line like
this no we cannot if it passes through
the second third and the fourth quadrant
the segment formed between the x and the
y axis is this but the midpoint has to
lie on the segment not outside it for
the same reasons a line like this is
also not possible the midpoint has to be
on the segment aligned like this
parallel to the y axis is also not
possible as the segment is not formed at
all this line will not intersect the
y-axis and this line which is parallel
to the x axis is also out of question as
it does not intersect the x axis this is
the only kind of line that makes sense
now that we know this is the segment
what do we need to do to find its slope
to find the slope all we need is the
coordinates of any two points on this
line we have one but how do we find the
other can we use the midpoint to find
the coordinates of the endpoints look at
the endpoints first this endpoint will
have coordinates X comma 0 and this
endpoint will have the coordinates 0
comma Y the endpoints can be named a X
comma 0 and B 0 comma Y what will be the
midpoint of a B the x coordinate of the
midpoint will be the average of the
x-coordinates of the endpoint it will be
X plus 0 over 2 and the y coordinate
will be 0 plus y over 2 that is the
average of the y-coordinates and this is
2 comma minus 3 this is the midpoint
that is given to us so x over
we'll equal to we get X as for and Y
over 2 is minus 3 so Y is minus 6 with
these values a will be 4 comma 0 and B
will be 0 comma minus 6 that's it we
have the endpoints and we can easily
find the slope the slope is defined as Y
minus y1 over X minus x1 using points a
and B we get 0 minus minus 6 as the
numerator and 4 minus 0 as the
denominator the slope will equal 3 over
2 let's review what we did first we
found out that this is the line the
question is talking about the end points
of the segment are X comma 0 and 0 comma
Y as we are told that it is the part of
the line between the X and the y-axis we
use the midpoint formula and found the
values of x and y and that gave us the
coordinates of the endpoints and with
the help of those coordinates we found
the slope of that line but sorry to
disappoint you again this is not the
best way to solve this problem this is
only a good way to understand it yes but
do you know how much time you should
have ideally taken to solve it not more
than one second that's all if the
midpoint of the segment is X comma Y
then the slope of that line will be
minus y over X here the midpoint was 2
comma minus 3 and the slope is minus of
minus 3 over 2 remember this well if the
midpoint is X comma Y then the slope is
minus y over X
you